okay
ready on order four covers table ten
four oyster soup main course four turkey
yes one no breadcrumbs watch that table
yes
russell and miller are the two commies
in the kitchen this evening by the end
of tonight
one is gonna win a job in one of my
restaurants and the other one's going
home
[ __ ] you're nearly going home
watch the tickets please russell i'm
trying to run a [ __ ] hot plate here
and you're knocking them all over the
place yeah come on
yeah you're like a baby [ __ ]
rhinoceros come on
russell move your ass table six yes four
weeks of soup yeah yeah
try and serve it before [ __ ] midnight
now tonight's starter is oysters and
champagne with a cucumber papridelli
don't turn your nose about oysters they
are delicious and a real gourmet treat
if you don't like raw oysters try
cooking them because they taste amazing
and can be enjoyed by the most squeamish
guests now first of all gotta open the
oysters don't be scared of doing this
because
it's actually quite straightforward all
we have to do is get the knife and
pierce inside the muscle
not at the side not at the end because
that's where the shell is really brittle
just push down on top of the oyster
until you get through
and then just twist and the shell just
pops off
open up just cut through the muscle
and out into the bowl
these are rock oysters and they're from
devon and they're one of the tastiest
you can get this time of year
right cucumber not too much cucumber yes
all we do is get the peeler
place the cucumber down and peel
these really nice strips of cucumber
and they not only look fantastic but it
means they actually sort of
look identical to papadely pasta and
they take seconds to cook
bring to the boil a couple of ladles of
vegetable stock add the cucumber
oyster juice and the cream bring back to
the boil
and add your oysters you've really got
to move your ass because the oyster is
overcooked within seconds so
you've really got to be quick and 30
seconds off the heat
next add a pinch of salt and a
sprinkling of fresh chives
and then we're gonna finish the soup
with champagne
the only thing that's missing now a
touch of lettuce and that literally goes
in
seconds before you serve it
take your cucumber
and that is a fantastically light tasty
sumptuous
beautiful soup that's been finished with
champagne
and lettuce service please double seven
jean-baptiste
ali use a ladle please we're gonna be
all night so russell i said a ladle i
can't keep on telling you again yes
there's no lettuce in there
oh come on excuse me get me the suit
back from the table
gordon is every happy week so sorry
hurry up jump yeah apparently
yeah you find it's funny you're laughing
away i want the [ __ ] suit back
just get the [ __ ] bowl from the table
let's go two more pans
what happened there miller half the
table had lettuce the other table didn't
give her a pan please
[Music]
back up to the boil quickly
and the oysters are overcooked let's
start again hurry up
hello ladies no you've got the best
table in the house he's all to yourself
i'm a lucky man do you enjoy your
oysters it's very good first time as
well oh really anything happening
downstairs
not quite yet i love you later mighty
should i have half an hour ago
huh dear i do
how are you donny good to see you thank
you
merry christmas merry christmas welcome
welcome welcome now
christmas yes in the osborne household
yes that must be mad no
it's really you know hustle bustle
hectic dogs kids yeah the whole lot
like i can imagine aussie biting the
head off a turkey before it goes neal
but no he ends up
cooking it he does he ends up cooking
because i can't
i can't believe that he does the [ __ ]
cooking in your house what's he like
what kind of things does he cook good
old english thick chips he says and
they're brilliant
ready you get excited about going out to
dinner with good food i do
i really i you know there's such a
difference between
good food and food now it's been well
documented
your relationship with food bulimia for
instance it's a thing of
when we all need to eat and i would need
to eat but i would hate the fact that i
needed to eat so i'd want to get rid of
it
yeah and then i i just wouldn't feel
clean i had to just get it out of my
body because it was crap that i was
eating i mean that's all under control
now that's been
yeah yeah yeah it is extraordinary the
fact that you look
amazing how did you keep it up and what
was the last thing you had done oh
cosmetics yes
my boobs your boobs yeah but i don't
like them now they're too big so i'm
gonna have them changed
does aussie think they're too big no he
likes them but they're amazing you don't
need to change them
no they're too big they weigh and
honestly seriously they
weigh a lot and it's like man yeah never
had oysters before
i haven't because i think they look like
bogies
big bogeys jean-baptiste
oh did you hear that that accent
no i don't think you're going to chew
sharon being shown you're going to
swallow
ready baby does it have a little smell
it smells like an old fanny this is a
high quality oyster you can absolutely
i can't believe you just said that by my
oyster
i'll take this big one ready so till
down finger
all right let's smell your breath now
and the low fat as well this one is
can't wait it feels like a testicle
all right come back straight down
what was that like it's like being
bleeding brighton and taking a mouthful
of sea water
damn you didn't like that no that's
supposed to be an aphrodisiac
he's aussie in for a good night not with
this breath he's not
it'll murder him next on the menu
the kids get to eat anthony and if
things go wrong i'll be stuck with a
family of vegetarians
bye anthony bye watch let's go
i'm off to harrogate in north yorkshire
to get a vicar's wife back in the
kitchen
the freezer is central to my cookie give
us this day our daily bread
and i'll leave the comments in charge of
the kitchen so it could be me that ends
up stuffed
is it [ __ ] warm no no so you want to
serve that
now get the sprouts off and get them in
the [ __ ] pan let's go
[Applause]
russell you're sending table 16 16
million table three
table three welcome back to the f-word
now next up the main course
home-grown roasted turkey
turkey the one hit wonder an absolute
amazing bird
stuff onion orange garlic
thyme and bailey season
truffle butter this little beauty helps
to take the turkey to a different
division these cost 50 quid for that
size
yes it's expensive but boy is it worth
[Music]
it
don't chop the truffle too small because
we want to taste
and identify the truffle
parsley tarragon
salt touch of pepper
tablespoon of olive oil and that stops
the butter from burning
take your piping bag and fill it
separate skin from meat
[Music]
bag pie butter
massage salt
pepper olive oil
roast
citrus breadcrumbs
[Music]
pancetta
[Applause]
onion
you don't need a good old chef trick and
pull down
and just peel it off it's lovely flowers
pine nuts
butter
bread orange
lemon
[Music]
[Applause]
and to start browning sprinkle your
orange and lemon breadcrumbs
lemon juice
[Applause]
there we go beautiful
rest tin foil keeps it nice and warm and
it cools down slowly
so the breasts become really nice and
moist calm
what you can smell of course is that
amazing truffle
absolutely beautiful
turkey with truffle butter and citrus
breadcrumbs done
now let me show you something quick come
here anthony
nigello and dean are all in the oven
have a quick look
don't touch there you go that's anthony
in there
for the past three months my kids megan
holly jack and matilda have been rearing
their own turkeys for christmas
tonight they'll finally get to eat them
wave goodbye anthony quick you're in
there you
bye anthony bye watch out go right
at the table up at the table
he's gone he's going in the oven come on
at the table matilda
dear idea [ __ ] here now
now four minutes on hot plate yet so
move your ass yeah a little bit of
energy yes
in fact lots of energy yes and yes it is
a race miller
let's go down now with the turkey we're
serving roast potatoes carrots and
brussels sprouts
brussels sprouts always get a hard time
and we only get to eat them once a year
however
do not put a cross at the bottom like my
mum does when you criss-cross the bottom
of that you end up with them soggy
overcooked sprout leave them whole into
the boiling water
and cook for three and a half to four
minutes then take them out and dump them
straight in ice water so it stops them
from ever cooking
then we're going to saute them very very
quickly with some almonds
so the sprouts just start to color and
the almonds just start going that really
nice not brown
flavor now the roast potatoes that go
with the turkey are charlotte's
they're small rich and very waxy so you
don't need to part ball them before you
roast them
and this way the flavour is
extraordinary into the pan season and
color on the stove
in goose or duck fat and if you give the
potatoes colour
before they go in the oven you get this
really nice crispy
flavor around the outside
come on come on come on really important
now the fingers are moving fast yes come
here you don't serve it
are you happy with that yeah reasonable
you are yes haven't even tested it to
see
it's warm yeah you should still warm
because this bits warm as well
yeah touch that there come on russell
yeah that's not quite a wall
is it [ __ ] warm no it's not no so do you
want to serve that
no chef no get the sprouts off and get
them in the [ __ ] pan let's go
so delicious turkey nice hot potatoes
yeah roasted carrots and [ __ ] stone
cold brussels sprouts come on
right russell come here miller come here
that wasn't good enough
[Applause]
a little bit all over the shop you know
that you stone cold vegetables your
turkey
carving is shocking how can you call
that carved
it's like you've been in there with a
[ __ ] shovel if i had to make the
decision on those last two tables there
russell you'd be going home
pull it back one table of five each
let's go again
how about getting the turkey sliced on
the tray this time yeah
getting your vegetables piping hot yeah
and plating your turkey
and your veg at the same time yes here
we go
make it count move your ass yes
clean your [ __ ] place come on
nice portions piping hot veg
let's go good well done big boy yes
you saved your skin there big boy go
double 12. nice
go please come on miller
yes 12 please go
[Music]
right i'm going to nip in there how was
nigella breast moist i have to say
you you've pulled off the hardest thing
in turkey cooking
really which is moist breast with i'm a
turkey skeptic
i know you are you're a plucking [ __ ]
finicky turkey grower uh
yes and i and i'm fussy about turkey yes
and very very rarely is it cooked
properly yes and that's really hard to
put off so it's coming from you
i'm honored thank you no it was really
really good how do you feel about
nigella being a man
confused nigella a man cared for by jack
h5 i mean there's a
provenance i mean i like menus where
they talk about the provenance
you know traceability yeah traceability
now i'll see you later for dessert yes
i'll see you for the pudding challenge
how are you feeling about that i'm
slightly nervous
huh good to see you
the turkey is lovely and moist there's a
lot of lemon in it
sometimes i'm not sure about lemon yeah
so much lemon but i did enjoy it and i
thought that
the actual texture of the meat is lovely
and the sprouts
are just the kind of al dente that i
struggle to get
she said you're a little duck hey good
to see you
what have you noticed different about
your sprouts and my sprouts
excuse me excuse me
don't you start ganging up on me there
was no criss-crosses on my
spreadsheet so they weren't soggy mom
now we sell them all for once
see you shortly yes
given his christmas i thought i'd get a
vicar's wife back in the kitchen
and believe me she needed a miracle
christmas for a vicarage family i would
say it's wall-to-wall church
mark does all the cooking except at
christmas when it does fall to me
i don't think i've ever really learned
to cook give us this day our daily bread
the freezer is central to my cooking and
forgive us our trespasses as we forgive
them that trespass against us
an alternative christmas lunch will be
would be interesting
the ideal christmas meal for me would be
something that could be prepared in
advance
that was easily cooked and served but
that also
was exciting and that i had done for
myself and i would really love to see
the family's face when i put that down
hi ruth hi gordon how are you all right
how are you
i feel like santa claus great glad to
see you
um christmas yeah what's the problem
on christmas morning i'm up really early
trying to
um prepare vegetables or whatever can be
done in advance
which is where i get really stressed my
solution to this of course it would be
something simple
and something like a salmon on crude
right
you can get prepped yes go off
to church return cook in the oven yeah
once that's cooked in the oven
then you get the vegetables on that will
be done within the time of the salmon
being cooked fantastic first and
foremost important get the salmon done
so it's just going to be um layers of
salmon sandwich together
between the fillets maybe some butter
sultanas some ginger some lemon and
thyme and the nice thing about this
particular dish is quite
yeah it's quite festive there's the
salmon it's been skinned
pinbone get the butter paste this all
over the sound
we get the head and the tail yeah
opposite one
right so lift up the salmon
place that on there any particular
reason for that is it so it cooks evenly
this is short crust yeah roll the pastry
out
get the salmon into the pastry i'm gonna
use an egg wash to stick this together i
want you to brush
around the whole rim nice and lift over
on your tray that goes in the fridge
excellent imagine it's christmas morning
right someone's done yeah big weight off
your shoulders you're back from the
church what's next
check the oven temperature yep whack it
up and then get the salmon yeah
straight in and we're gonna do like a
creamed leek looks fantastic at the
table it tastes amazing
and we're gonna season with a little bit
of curry powder right don't worry a
little bit of wash on there please
we don't need dirty leaks on christmas
day do we
oh that'll spread like wildfire around
here yes the vicar's wife's got dirty
leaves
so leaks into the pan nice and
lightly seasoned with curry powder yeah
that's delicious cream in the leeks
right job done take it out beautiful
nice slowly it feels really
meaty that slice is beautiful i want you
to put the potatoes on all right
main ingredient in the left-hand side of
the plate look at that
cream leeks there we go now my dear
vicar's wife
yes you're
happy christmas wow
now how was that really good it's very
nice yes
yeah and ruth not too stressed out very
chilled fantastic
i've never said this to a vicar before
but get out the kitchen
yes and stay in the church where you
belong
new year's resolution get back in the
kitchen absolutely
merry christmas bye bye-bye
hello ruth how are you nice to see you
mark how are you
well yeah fine thank you are you feeling
less scared now about cooking
are you done a bit you've done a bit of
it fantastic
try the pastry again and it didn't stick
to the pin oh ready plenty of flour
that's great news fantastic well done
nice to see you thank you thank you
merry christmas thank you
how's the turkey it's really nice yes
very nice
um as you know it's been my objective to
get women back in the kitchen and
it's gone very well thousands of
requests not just from desperate
housewives but some from
men as well and one that really sort of
i suppose touched my heart what's this
man
sharon happens to be in my opinion the
worst cook on the face of the earth
she couldn't even make a piece of dogs
without burning gordon would you do me a
big favor i'm fed up of having takeaway
food delivered to my house
teach it to the cook um what would i
really like lamb chops and mean sauce
he likes lamb chocolate very much
teacher please
please i'm starving oh when did you do
that
it was his plea it was his message to me
together how cute is he
listen that's one man i definitely don't
want to do upset come on mrs osborne
it's good to have you in the kitchen i
can do this right i know i can't
now these are very simple lamb chops pan
onto the stove
this olive olive oil that's right if i
start it off with butter
it'll burn too quickly so it goes black
so a little bit
in nice hot pan rumors has it
okay that you didn't even realize hey
how to work the oven and be what was in
your kitchen for
is that true you weren't that bad no my
oven
has always had the instructions how to
work it still inside
taped to the side of the oven because i
never turn it on no it was my husband's
hiding place for his booze because he
knew i'd never opened it
unbelievable and he's weak to have his
everything and everything and his
rosemary
special rosemary moroccan black yes all
right i want you to turn them now
they're ready for turning
there's one thing on there like that and
turn it over now be careful you don't
don't don't smash yourself
now my kids are constantly banging on
about me even at the age of seven
six and five that i'm embarrassing every
time i go out do your kids ever get
embarrassed about some of the things
that you say and do
please my kids have been so i mean come
on look at them
i know i know come on can you imagine
the old man and me turning up at parents
night at school
i mean my kids went through hell and
back with us
i mean they're dead turning up in black
velvet and all his jewelry for school
meetings
and sports though he used to fall asleep
at parents meetings
snoring yeah honestly but no matter what
this is the one thing no matter what you
look like
what you do every kid is still
embarrassed so you might as well be
something to be embarrassed about yeah
i'm gonna make a little doggie bag now
and take these back
the best thing to do is keep them
wrapped in the tin foil okay put a
little bubble butter in there
yes and into the oven
and what would be best to serve with
that with that you know what
a nice mashed potato you know how to
make a mashed potato
yeah you get powder and you pour boiling
water in it oh
okay i'm gonna come around christmas day
you know that
i'll have some help i'll see you in a
minute yes
next on the menu it's dessert time hugh
furley whittingstall takes me on with
his chocolate chestnut truffle cake
suddenly all your confidence is just
sapping away and sean osborne
is doing the judging one of them
i really love and the other one i do not
like
and charles cohen finds out why we
should eat christmas dinner every day
they're less likely to become addicted
to alcohol
cigarettes drugs so sitting there in
front of the tv eating their tv dinners
basically
they're turning themselves into the
crackheads of tomorrow
these tables from my wife yes and
children let's go
one table i do not want to [ __ ] up come
on let's go go up
wakey wakey
good holly what do you think good
good yes megan nice hmm
jack what do you think i'm good and you
like the brown meat as well
yeah matilda what do you think of
anthony nice
does he taste the way you thought he was
gonna taste oh no
so you want to have turkeys back in the
garden again just what about pigs in the
garden
yeah pig
what do you think about matilda's idea
with chickens pigs is probably
more encouraging you're happy with the
pigs yes mommy said yes to the pigs
that's fantastic news i'm gonna get back
to the kitchen
yes we'll take some of your teacher give
me a kiss
see you later i'm going back to work
back in the kitchen
right listen clean plates yes or
no dessert yes hopefully
chocolate tart see you later ice cream
now this man hugh fury wooden store is
going to attempt to beat me with his
chocolate chestnut cake
no chance you reckon
um what are you doing exactly i'm going
to do a a
nice gooey chocolate and chestnut cake
nice should be quite soft and moussey
in the middle it's one of the things you
could you can literally eat it straight
out of the oven
as a kind of hot chocolate pudding yeah
good
and you won't even manage to slice it
you just have to scoop it out oh nice
good luck good luck so i'm doing a very
simple straightforward
chocolate tart no frills no spills no
creme fresh no vanilla
chocolate tart with roasted hazelnuts um
we're gonna make
the most amazing pastry roll it out line
it in this
flan ring put the cream of milk on to
boil
add that to my little chocolate buttons
there's a
very well known elizabeth david
chocolate cake that uses ground almonds
instead of flour and keeps it lovely and
moist and
quite fudgy in the middle this is really
based on that except i'm just using
chestnuts cooked in a little cream and
milk mash instead of the ground almonds
but
really it's a tribute to her recipe it's
lovely at christmas because it's got the
chestnuts in
milk cream up to the ball hazelnut
praline
on top of the chocolate buttons and then
quite simply
cream and milk onto the chocolate
and stir away now the thickening agent
of this particular tart
are whole eggs and what the egg does is
as the cream and the chocolate
and the milk cook of course the eggs
help to set it
lightly whisk up the eggs and fold that
in to the chocolate
now i'm just going to lightly toast my
nuts now
you're highly competitive aren't you
even though you're living in the
countryside you still have that
chef's competitiveness streak in you
don't you yeah
i yeah i i like to win gordon whoa
no it's all right you thought it had all
gone horribly wrong for me there didn't
you
i was hoping it had you know that's cute
i'd get fired from your kitchen so fast
when i look at my part look at that
look oh my god does that actually bring
you out in a sweater
i'd be getting clip around the head if
this was i probably am about to be
clipped by the head when you fire from
the river cafe for being a messy puppy
yes yes in a word yes
bit in the heck there we go
we're baking the tart blind that means
we're going to line this ring with a
pastry
and then bake that off first so that's
an added insurance policy that a the
pastry stays nice and crisp and b
all we have to do then is just cook the
chocolate filling so baking blind
simply means cooking it twice
you miss not being a professional chef
running a restaurant
full time i don't miss it at all because
i was quite i was quite a bad
professional chef
really i just i you know i have a bit
like jamie
i haven't got the discipline but what i
do now i i enjoy very much you know
what we do in dorset isn't really a
restaurant it's more informal than that
it's about telling people where the food
comes from i have a great kitchen team
but it's sort of more of a cookery
school than a restaurant
and um did you have long straggly hair
at the river cafe
i've always had long straggly hair how
many times a year do you wash it
i think i'm due for about once a month
seasonal
seasonal did you have to wear a hair nap
i could be due for my pre-christmas wash
any day now
you're distracting me and you're making
me over whip the egg whites
the thing about folding in egg whites is
never fold more than you need to but you
do have to get it
properly incorporated which means going
deep to the bottom of the bowl and just
lifting the mix and that's it
and in it goes that just goes in there
for
25 minutes the really important not to
overcook it so that you don't want it to
dry out
so out
nuts sprinkle the nuts at the bottom
chocolate in does look very good we
don't fill the tart
right to the very top here two thirds of
the way in
open the oven door
and then get the rest of your mixture
and top up the tart
uh so that's so you don't have to carry
a really full tart over to the exactly
so it gets really nice and full that's
obviously a very useful tip for chefs
who've been drinking too much on
christmas day
absolutely oh [ __ ]
i dropped the cloth in it i've already
messed up my pudding
are you okay yeah i just went in to have
a little look and i dropped the cloth
you see that's why i got fired things
like that i dropped the cloth in the
middle of my cake i hope that's a clean
one
now it's all down to [ __ ] sharon
osbourne you know that and you know i've
got for the first time
in the f-word series a proper chef in my
kitchen so if there's any time now that
i really want to win it's [ __ ] today
that's very kind of you to describe me
as a chef i'm not a good loser you know
that
huh well you better be i got i'm now in
that state of mind where i actually
really want to win
seriously yeah mine's in the oven now
it's got to go in there and 90 degrees
for an hour and ten to an hour and
fifteen minutes so it cooks nice and
slowly we can't afford to turn up any
higher than 90
95 degrees otherwise it splits and
separates
and i'm damned if i'm gonna lose this
challenge
for me the best thing about christmas of
course the food the worst thing about
christmas
the leftovers now i've come to see a
bunch of guys that just can't escape
from that unwanted turkey
don't cast the prison may not be
renowned for his good food but like many
prisons it runs a professionally
recognised catering course
to help rehabilitate inmates
this is our kitchen gordon again with
bars on there
yes huh flip an egg this is a real
health kitchen [ __ ] hell
there are three and a half thousand
meals a day going out of this kitchen
three and a half thousand meals a day
yes
not too concerned about my dog tag i'm
just concerned the fact that i can get
the [ __ ] out of here now it's time
that's all okay
turkey leftover curry hi guys
i'll be cooking with kieran baby
daz and jaco
i'm told they're the keenest cooks on
x-wing serious broomer has it
ah and you're supposed to be a sort of
curry expert
yeah i won't say it next to it no but
you love a curry
i like it for the year yeah curry is the
most popular dish in the prison
and it's also a great way to deal with
leftover christmas turkey
so i'm going to show the men of x-wing
how to make a thai red curry uh red
chillies
okay obviously garlic lemongrass
and ginger have you used lemongrass
before
no no cut it in half okay
yeah have a little smell lovely
and that's pretty nice and fragrant you
smell that before
have a smell that lovely fresh
lemongrass
beautiful and that'll do just because it
smells nice and sweet almost like
vanilla
really nice and lemony and fresh and
fragrant that lightens up
the curry so this is where we make the
paste
and the way to mix it now is just get
all the ingredients into a blender
[Applause]
we're doing it today with turkey but you
know this paste is great
if you're making a fish curry right
there's your onion yes there's my onion
oh
no no no no no no hold on hold on let's
have a competition you know how
competitive chefs are yes
huh right what do you reckon we're
taking with the first uh
half orange reckon they'll be finished
before me
he's pretty good right knife down the
whole thing
chopped and ready to go right
come on karen
first half
[Applause]
hold on a minute
hey hey fancy john
hey i'm serious fancy a job yeah not 25
good a week big boy 25 quid a day
yeah when you're out 2007.
okay 2007 give me a call and come spend
a day with me at the kitchen okay
to make the curry we fry off the onions
add our curry paste
and then pour in coconut milk for a rich
creamy flavor
then as it cooks down we add some
monster for colour
and a bit of bite what they're called
garden then they're called monge2
or snow peas snow peas yeah
it gives a really nice sort of um
texture slightly sweet as well
now the turkey meat that makes it
through
nice keep on mixing that in my man yeah
back up to the bowl
um now with the rice we're going to make
a almost like a a sticky rice
and we've got some creamed coconut here
and the idea of course is to get the
rice cut up the coconut
and then just crumble that through there
like this yep
then from there sprinkle
the coriander through there and what it
does it makes a really nice
fragrant rice
okay um 30 minutes of the rice yeah once
that's cooking um i'd love to go and
look where you uh boy sleep in the cell
excellent coffee and smaller yeah
who snores the loudest tough
really you yeah farts the loudest
you might have lied out that's right
that's yours
[Laughter]
how's the rice lovely
good we get over there hi big boy smells
lovely
yes finished with fresh coriander thank
you yeah good man
so what do you recommend so far yeah yes
yes really nice
right enjoy that yeah beautiful merry
don't be late look at that suddenly all
your confidence is just sapping away
you're absolutely [ __ ] right that's
really that's ready for sharon
now look it's not quite firm but
it's good isn't it you want it a bit
gooey a little bit gooey let's try it
wee
oh that looks beautiful it does look
very very nice
homemade villain ice cream looks lovely
mr wedding stall it does look rather
yummy that you know that i'm slightly
concerned that it looks too
[ __ ] good however it's gonna be close
isn't it gonna be very close
they look great they both look good
aren't they can i just they do look
fantastic i just have a little sliver of
yours yeah cool come on just a little
[Applause]
all right please all right have a little
bit of this one
and the cream
it's very good it's incredibly rich
okay jean-baptiste take them over to
sharon hope she likes them
yes yep hey listen remember
she doesn't you're [ __ ] yes we have a
job i know that yeah
i'm fed up with [ __ ] losing
hello sharon what have i got i'm fine
here we go so we have two desserts yes
so i need to try
the first one i love dessert
it's my favorite part of the meal i love
to
meet you
[Applause]
this is interesting have you made your
mind on this one
yeah okay so this is number two
[Music]
compared to the first one
well let's leave it like this
[Applause]
one of them i really love
and the other one i do not like i'm very
excited
i'm brexit you've been working really
hard i've been having a lovely dinner
i know i'm in the state of deep
relaxation about this
hi huh how are you sorry sharon hugh
very well
this is very tense you know that why
well because well i must say that i have
heard
that your desserts have not been going
down great no
rumor has it on the street yes
pressure's on i
am the chocolate queen good fantastic
the winner is which one would you go
back to a restaurant for
okay this is the one that's absolutely
and completely [ __ ]
wonderful jesus christ
and what about this one with the
hazelnuts i would never eat that
that is [ __ ] brilliant i was born i
did love you
i do love you too oh my god this is
wonderful can i finish it please do
can i spoon feed you oh yes darling that
was just
fabulous mmm hugh
sharon yes darling may i yes please what
else do you cook here
what do you like gordon no you must
come on
next on the menu it's decision time i
give one of the comments
the break of a lifetime a job in my
kitchens
the person that i'm gonna offer a job to
is and charles curran here's an amazing
excuse for eating in front of the telly
there's always the excuse the dog always
needs something that's no good you eat
in front of the telly because the dog at
the table
[Applause]
welcome back to the f-word now time to
find out what our diners thought about
the dessert
did they agree with sharon's stupid
verdict let's go russell
light moist chocolatey gooey i mean
it's great the queen that he made with
his with his sitanas
was fantastic very tasty but a little
bit too sweet
and a bit too rich
christmas is hard work but not for our
professional eater
giles corin he wishes every day was
christmas day
[Music]
at this shopping center it's been
christmas every day since the end of
october
but what if it really worked what if we
had christmas lunch every day of the
year well presumably we'd all be fat
broke and miserable because christmas
dinner is famously fattening expensive
and stressful
but maybe we've got it all wrong there's
some convincing evidence around that if
we ate christmas lunch every day we
would in fact be happier healthier and
better off
the first excellent reason to have
christmas lunch every day is that it's a
meal you prepare from scratch
and not a ready meal that means it's
like to be a lot better for you
well if you look at these labels you see
a list of additives and preservatives
and many of them are high in salt and
fat
so you've got less control over what
you're eating so so christmas dinner is
better for us than what people eat every
day
well if you think about it turkey breast
without the skin is a great low-fat
source of protein
you've got carrots parsnips brussels
sprouts a great selection of vegetables
helping you to achieve your recommended
five a day but don't smother them in
butter
no salt that's the key steamed
vegetables lightly cooked
then you've got your potatoes well if
you keep them large
keep the skin on explain if you keep
them large they absorb less fat
so actually you've got a lower fat
potato just by keeping the potatoes
larger so a big
flowery not too crunchy potato with its
skin on
sounds delicious it certainly does
another potentially worrying thing about
eating christmas lunch every day
is that it costs so much money it is a
big family occasion
and it is a big meal so do you think
it's more expensive than a normal meal
i would say yes i think you must go a
little bit extra at christmas with the
food
preparation everything kills you but
that's where you're wrong
because the second reason to have
christmas lunch every day is that it's
actually a bargain
according to the good housekeeping
institute your christmas food shop
actually costs 40
less than your normal food shop you go
to the
supermarket and you buy all these
ingredients and then when you take them
home you can cook
one big meal but then you have leftovers
yeah everything else this is the famous
turkey curry that i've heard so much
about
exactly and turkey sandwiches and turkey
souffle and turkey creme brulee
that's right turkey turkey pasta turkey
rice risotto
stir-fries sandwiches well i think
that's about enough turkey
the third reason we should have
christmas lunch every day is that it's a
meal we eat at the table
with our family unlike the rest of the
year
where do you read you in front of the
telly or yeah at the moment
mostly the dog at the table
there's always an excuse the dog always
needs something that's not good you eat
in front of the telly because the dog at
the table
they're not alone a recent survey found
that three quarters of people eat dinner
in front of the tv
and one in five families only eat
together once a week
so why does it matter then why why
should we all sit around together eating
a
freshly prepared meal instead of sitting
in front of the tv i don't see why
well if you're sitting down and you're
eating and you're watching television
then you're not speaking
to each other and communication is
actually the way that we form strong
bonds in a family
is there any proof i mean it sounds a
nice idea is there any proof that it's
true
i mean there have been loads of surveys
into this particular subject but there's
a really big survey to thousands of
teenagers and their parents
by the university of columbia and that
stretched out over 10 years and it found
that
it sort of improves children's skills
communication wise their academic skills
they're less likely to become addicted
to alcohol
cigarettes drugs are less likely to
become addicted to drugs if they sit
down to a square meal every night yeah
absolutely so sitting there in front of
the tv eating their tv dinners basically
they're turning themselves into the
crackheads of tomorrow
well i suppose you could say that
there you have it eating christmas lunch
every day could make you happier
healthier
and better off and best of all it might
make your children less likely
to end up on crack
[Music]
right i've got a present for you yes um
i've thought long and hard
and spent a fortune on it and something
that i've been dying to sort of give you
is there heavy yes
you excuse me
anything to get you more notice now make
you look a bit taller try them on
hey i've already got a pair no
[Applause]
give the audience a 12 give up give a
little tell over there give us
yes
tonight the f word commission i've been
fighting out for a job in my kitchen
how are you totally [ __ ] it i didn't
think i did myself just this
well we all make mistakes just how are
you i really enjoyed being in the in the
kitchen
it was um yeah it was the hardest it's
been
it all began three months ago when i
scoured the country to find new chefs
with promise
over a thousand applied we shortlisted
12.
now what in the [ __ ] do we have here
each week
two copies have gone head-to-head in the
f-word kitchen
now two remain but only one of them will
get a job with me
russell he's creative quietly confident
and he has flair
good well done big boy yes
but sometimes his judgment is off taste
it
you tasted it yes chef yeah and i think
it's okay chef
class is never cooked stop if i don't
win i would be
absolutely gutted miller
she's a fast learner confident and she
has an eye for detail
one minute nicely sourced
but the question is can she cope with
pressure
having got this far i really want to win
this
miller look at the pass that's going in
the bin
where's your passion there's a lot of
passion i hope you realize by now
um that i'm obsessed with all things
food
people look at me and tell me i'm crazy
why do you want to do this i
because of the food because i want to
work with food because i want to cook
so you're not really just posh tattoo
you really want to cook for a living i
really want to cook for a living
you really want you really want to cook
for a living yeah describe your day
today i felt that i've done crap to be
honest
i just didn't perform i felt you've got
to be able to take the pressure
and when the [ __ ] is the fan it hits the
fan yeah and
my reputation's at stake as well if you
can't handle this this evening
and you made so many [ __ ] ups what's it
gonna be like when you're in a real
serious kitchen well that's why i wanna
have that opportunity to try and get
myself
up to scratch i feel that you're a
person that can actually iron me out
anyway my conclusion to you both if
you've come a long way
i have to base my decision on
individuals that can
absorb more be push more and ones that
can become
stronger under more pressure and the
person that i'm going to offer a job to
is camilla well done thank you
i'm well done to you well done thank you
and well done to you yeah yes don't give
up yeah
keep cooking stay focused yes and push
yourself
yeah well done okay thank you
thanks for watching the f word hope you
enjoyed your meal please please keep
cooking
you've got to eat so you may as well eat
well happy
plucking christmas
you